[Music]
and permanent mistake news submitted by
Michaela loves JK I love a white couple
gave birth to an Asian child and it
ruined their marriage well what else
would it do yeah strengthen it that's
the data something and the baby is not
that and you came from the wife how [ __ ]
it up was this IVF oh so this is like
that like they [ __ ] up like the IVF
[ __ ] oh yeah because I first miss it IVF
I was like wait what friend IV friend
Valentine I was like what's got to do
with immigration yeah yeah so this
couple from New Jersey
they'd it's not an episode of Mari where
the [ __ ] baby comes out black and
then the white guys like it's a really
big birthmark right the chick gotta try
she's got a try at that point okay
they claim that the ivf clinton or the
clinic that they did the IVF with back
in 2012 used a stranger's sperm for
their $500,000 ivf treatment oh my god a
million dollars and they can't even get
the kid to look like you that's the most
expensive what you paid for
come on the most expensive unwanted baby
yeah half a mil yeah
that's a business right there their
daughter was born in 2013 six weeks
premature and the baby had to be kept in
the neonatal neonatal intensive care
unit for weeks and so they're saying
that by the time the little girl turned
to that's when her they noticed that her
appearance had like she had aged in
features did you turn 2 years old when
she was 2 that's what I like how they
[ __ ]
like it's a plague and [ __ ] oh no guys
he's going Asian what happened we
watched a couple kung fu movies not that
many I told you you shouldn't be eating
all that time and during the pregnancy
you [ __ ] that's a thief and Express is
a terrible idea we should have coffee
and a couple of times just a couple
times she's loved that movie all babies
do look kind of Asian in the first-born
at first because they don't have the
epic APNIC Ford not after two years
though yeah yeah after one they should
develop do Tiger looks like a Asian kid
yeah I'm like dang bro that is dominant
verb like punch to the way some people
think Tiger looks Mexican a little bit
yeah we fought hard for the next good
side bought really hard those jeans got
their asses yours are gonna get jobs I
don't know I can't wait I can't wait
my kids my all my kids should look like
Nikki it'll be great boy or girl they'll
be hot especially the boys he touched my
life to us to my son I built that cap to
you
oh yes so they're saying that so in 2015
when the little girl was two years old
they had a DNA test done and it
confirmed that the dad was zero percent
probability that she was biological the
daughter so then they're saying that
you're devastated and shocked they were
in complete disbelief but we're so
disgusted and they asked what's a return
policy love the kid like a lovely cat
cora's but it's it's like you donated
your spur you you froze your a and the
sperm so you expect the child to be
looking like you it's your creation I
just totally understand they were saying
that it was it was supposed to be
implanted right after they got the sperm
so it wasn't even burnt frozen so like
where the [ __ ] to the mix of happy yeah
she cheated yeah I'd hate to be that
person when they trace back the [ __ ]
paper trail and they're like this
[ __ ] who did I need to be back
yeah exactly so right now
yeah so right now they've been ordered
to turn over a list of sperm donors that
were around that same day and time ward
yeah but at least the mom is the mom
though right yeah so these are right
eggs is the right egg that is a bummer
though to find out that your kids are
your kid yeah but like it's one of yours
that's true that even clarifier
confronted articles whether or not I
would say makes oh man yeah have you
been scared Asian the city with half
asian looking it's okay cause it's still
the moms yeah but they wanted a pure as
white paid for that's why I [ __ ] paid
for when I got the discount if they
wanna even kid yeah it's like I wanted
the snow white one yeah we're like adopt
one you were got the deal imagine you
bargain for a Cadillac and you get like
Honduras literally a Honda like damage I
mean obviously more of like a genetic
like dude it's not my kid no matter what
race it would be I mean that's just
funny because if it'd have been a white
kid but it just like the features didn't
quite match and really I guess he
wouldn't never figure it out right yeah
and they're probably like Kate can you
trace it to what province is it a rich
Province in China and like sorry they
like oh so by November 2017 the couple
of 12 years split up in part because of
this whole nightmare shoe deal that's a
very common thing where a lot of
miscarriages things like this it can
break up a like the death of a child yes
oh yeah that's of a child yeah yeah yeah
and then even if they have other
children yeah like the point of where it
gets to but I also read that it's a
biological thing to where it's like your
body and Bing is saying like this /
you can't create children with you have
to try with another that is biological
lot of mammals like if like a dude wants
to [ __ ] that chick that dude just has to
go to that chick kill the chicks babies
and now all of a sudden that chick is
now extremely horny for that dude
gorillas do that but gorillas lion bears
a lot of meth that's why guys are shitty
to stepchildren but people don't care
about that bird but that's important to
know and the girls are super horny well
they should be well yeah Casey slept
Isaac another moment be a bit more horny
for him did you know the biological II
there's like guys like in there saying
like in human evolution there'll be like
guys that like girls friendzone and
they'll have them take care of the kids
but then there'll be guys that they they
actually want the kids with right so the
way that they found that out too is that
during ovulation women are attracted to
different body type and face and then
when they're not they're attracted to
another it goes back and forth yeah dude
I got a buddy whose wife was [ __ ]
repulsed by him while she was pregnant
like his smell would disgust her and she
was like I [ __ ] hate him now like I
can't stand the smell of him and cheaper
than anything a Chilean yeah crazy
breakup doing that I know but he was
like in another world dude like he was
like I remember we're at a bachelor
party and this cat was just like I was
like how's it going to home and he's
like man [ __ ] oh I just lied to him I
was like hey man I heard that your
chicks like super in those she loved
she's super painful hear from the girls
like just to give them that little bit
of [ __ ] something to cling on to
nothing nothing yeah sure I remember had
really heightened smell yeah so I wit
some I don't remember you being stinky I
just remember a lot of smells really
bothered me thank God yeah maybe that's
so you can smell poison yeah and you'd
be like this shit's bad I can't give it
to the bear then yeah maybe there's some
[ __ ] like that
maybe she smelled a stench on him
and she was like I hate you you
son-of-a-bitch but this is one of the
best dudes I know man I'm like this cat
is so dope he's such a good dude I'm my
all [ __ ] this is devastated so I had to
lie to this fool I had to I feel
terrible are you sure I betrayed my
friend please inflate my ego and lie to
me as much as possible I have and I will
thank you I like I like that commitment
please don't ever I was gonna be like I
beg you
you would Jess I beg you yeah let's be
done I got you all right so let me show
you photos of the family I'll see I'll
double well they do not look happy yeah
they don't look like they like Asians
[Laughter]
there's some white people that are like
little lava Asian baby they do not look
like the white couple denim like lovely
they don't look like techies from
Silicon Valley being had Asian babies
they had an Asian baby and they are you
[ __ ] kidding me
[Laughter]
they're like visual some of these
interview is like the guys that crying
cuz he's like you know I love my
daughter so much I heard China this
divorce already stupid so your photos
okay you don't mention the other kids I
don't know how this other kids involve
it it looks like they have two kids I
don't know anything at me always baby
damn are they that rich they could pay
them 500 it's a lot different with this
beard shave holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] she's just
like David Punk
they're like protecting her and self oh
dude do you think that's the kid oh okay
I thought I was wishing that that was
the big asian kid and they're like yeah
we'll just cover it for now later like
maybe we could go blonde with her or
something
oh yeah so now they so they're saying
like for him he wants to know if he's
fathered other children like with that
sperm that didn't end up getting news
from so and then he also wants to know
who the girl's biological father is
because they're saying that he passed
down like a genetic oh my gosh oh we
have additionally because of her like
her genetics she's had health issues Oh
and so they trying to like figure out
how to like this she shoot in the
[ __ ] bone dated that combat that's
what I was saying I'm like don't be a
vet this [ __ ] like well but I mean if it
was between her and or between him and
it's supposed to be between the two
people that are going into the clinic
right it's not like a random donor no
but they did say like they want to know
sperm donors I guess if you're a dad
trying to even if you're gonna use your
own sperm it's still a donor that works
maybe they gave the baby a little bit of
alcohol and turn red as [ __ ] and flip
them out he's like no you give a baby
alcohol to help him sleep
you know I've heard that before but my
grandma used to do and I turned out
pretty good yeah I think so I would
disagree I think I turn out work great
actually
Eddie slurs of the risk you know
[Music]